[Music]
three-year-old Dorothy was playing and
then accidentally fell down a flight of
stairs she hit her head and was knocked
unconscious when her parents found her
she wasn't breathing they called a
doctor who rushed over immediately
Dorothy's mother broke down when the
doctor said there was nothing he could
do her little girl was dead the doctor
left and returned an hour later with
Dorothy's death certificate and gently
discussed arrangements for the little
girl's body but during this conversation
shuffling Was Heard coming from
Dorothy's room they ran upstairs and
there she was playing in a room like
nothing happened the doctor examined her
again there was no sign of injury he had
no explanation he said it appeared as if
Dorothy had come back from the dead
he didn't realize how right he was
[Music]
Dorothy Edie was born in London in 1904
until her fall down the stairs and her
Resurrection she was a normal little
girl but after the fall she started
having night terrors her mother would
wake her and Dorothy would tell her
about the dream she was living in a huge
columned building surrounded by trees
and green Gardens it was always the same
dream and Dorothy would tell her mother
the same thing I want to go home when
her mother would tell her that she is
home Dorothy would become frustrated and
depressed sometimes Dorothy's parents
would find her pouting under the dining
room table they'd ask what's wrong and
it was always the same answer I want to
go home when she was asked where home
was Dorothy would say she didn't know
she just knew she wanted to get back
there after the fall Dorothy would
occasionally speak with a heavy foreign
accent this was so unsettling that
Dorothy's parents had trouble finding a
sitter when Dorothy was four her parents
planned a day at the British museum they
couldn't find anyone to watch their
daughter so they brought her along
that's when things got really strange as
expected four-year-old Dorothy was bored
in the museum she moped she dragged her
feet she acted like most four-year-olds
would act but Dorothy's mood drastically
changed when they reached the Egyptian
exhibit Dorothy was dazzled by the
artifacts but when she saw the Egyptian
statues she tore herself from her
mother's grip and ran wildly through the
Halls Dorothy was running from statue to
Statue kissing their feet and yelling at
people for wearing shoes in the presence
of gods Dorothy's mother was mortified
at her daughter's Behavior but then
Dorothy suddenly stopped and became
silent Dorothy's parents found her in
front of a glass case Frozen she was
staring at the face of an Egyptian mummy
Dorothy's mother picked her up but she
got upset then in a voice that sounded
like an old woman Dorothy said these are
my people it took Dorothy's parents a
few hours to finally drag her out of the
museum but whenever the family had free
time they would go back to the Egyptian
exhibit the only place where Darth they
felt happy and peaceful when Dorothy was
seven her father bought her a children's
encyclopedia about ancient Egypt Dorothy
spent hours studying hieroglyphics with
a magnifying glass the mother asked what
she was doing Dorothy would say I'm
trying to remember while reading a
Science magazine Dorothy came across a
picture of a temple built for the
Pharaoh City father of Ramses the Great
in the town of avenos Dorothy was
confused she asked her mother where all
the trees were and all the green Gardens
Dorothy's mother asked her what is this
place Dorothy smiled the biggest smile
she ever had in her entire life and
pointed to the picture of seti's Temple
in abados and said Mama this is my home
[Music]
children remembering their past lives is
more common than most people think there
are thousands of documented cases and
these are just the cases that parents
report there are certainly thousands
more cases where the parents are too
confused or too embarrassed to report it
one interesting story happened in
England in 1957 sisters Joanna and
Jacqueline Pollock aged 11 and 6 were
killed when a car lost control and
hopped the curb a year after the
accident the girl's mother Florence
Pollock gave birth to twin girls Julian
and Jennifer were identical twins but
they had different birthmarks Jennifer
had a birthmark on her waist that
matched a birthmark that Jacqueline had
before she died coincidence she also had
a scar on her forehead just like Jaclyn
did when the Twins were about two years
old they started asking for toys that
belonged to their sisters though they
never saw the toys before they would
also become frightened at moving cars
yelling how the car is coming to get
them and the coincidences go on and on
during the Battle of Iwo Jima the
Japanese shot down American fighter
pilot James Houston Jr he died in the
cockpit of the plane on March 3rd 1945
over 50 years later two-year-old James
leninger started having nightmares about
being a fighter pilot crashing into the
ocean and dying when James was shown
photos he was able to name the kind of
aircraft he flew he knew the name of the
aircraft carrier he was on he could even
name other men who served with him at
two years old and all this information
was verified to be true one of my
favorite cases of reincarnation is Ryan
Hammonds when Ryan was about four years
old and playing by himself he would
pretend to direct movies Ryan told his
mother that he used to be a man who
lived in Hollywood Ryan's parents were
Christian and serious about their faith
they didn't believe in reincarnation but
Ryan would often say I used to be
somebody else I used to be big but now
I'm little I liked it better when I was
big and I could go wherever I wanted to
go I hate being little whenever Ryan
would see the Hollywood sign on
television he would cry that that was
his home and he wanted to go back Ryan
would tell stories about meeting Rita
Hayworth about vacations in Paris and
working at an agency where people would
change their names this is not the
typical banter of a four-year-old one
day Ryan's mother brought home a book
about old Hollywood and they flipped
through the pictures they came across a
photo and Ryan said oh look that's
George we did a picture together oh that
guy's me they found me the other man in
the picture was Marty Martin he did know
Rita Hayworth he did vacation in Paris
and he did work at an agency where
people would change their name Ryan was
right about all of it Ryan even knew
Marty used to dance on Broadway how many
sisters he had how many children he had
Ryan even said his house was on a street
that had the word Rock in it Marty
Martin lived on Roxbury Drive Marty's
family was able to confirm 55 separate
facts that Ryan got correct at four
years old in these three cases like in
almost every case past life memories
start around age two or three and end
around age five not so with Dorothy Edie
as she got older her memories became
more clear it was just a matter of time
before Dorothy Edie would find out who
she really was three thousand years ago
[Music]
Dorothy Edie was very outspoken about
reincarnation she spoke about it openly
and didn't care what anybody thought
Beast she was and this was a problem for
a teenage girl in the 1920s her parents
tolerated what they thought was just an
eccentricity but other people weren't so
forgiving one Sunday afternoon a priest
showed up at the Edie's door the priest
said that Dorothy was no longer welcome
at Sunday school she had refused to sing
A Hymn that spoke poorly about Egypt but
the last straw was when Dorothy argued
with the Sunday school teacher that
Christianity was based on the old
religion of Egypt wasn't it well that's
debatable but there's plenty of evidence
that it was and he had come to Cummins
from Christians Dorothy had been
spending so much time in the British
museum that egyptologist sir E A Wallace
budge got to know her and started
teaching her how to read hieroglyphics
unsurprisingly she picked it up very
quickly like freakishly quickly
Dorothy's dreams continued this whole
time though now that she knew what was
happening she wasn't frightened anymore
when Dorothy was about 15 she would wake
up in the middle of the night almost
every night she heard the voice of a man
named Hora who asked her to write down
everything he said she would then go
into a trance neither sleeping nor awake
and scribble notes and hieroglyphics
when she woke up she had no idea what
she had written it wasn't even her
handwriting and after a year of this she
had 70 handwritten Pages she was finally
able to piece together that this was the
story of her life in ancient Egypt she
was an Egyptian woman named Ben treshit
born in the town of abados she came from
a humble background her father was a
soldier who served during seti the first
Reign her mother was a vegetable seller
when Ben shreshit was two years old her
mother died unable to care for Ben
shresher's father placed her in the
temple of com El Sultan where she would
be raised to become a priestess when she
was 12 years old ventricia was given two
choices she could either leave the
temple and go out into the world on her
own or become a consecrated virgin and
stay at the temple ventricity decided to
take the vows a few years later she met
Pharaoh seti the first and they had an
affair when she became pregnant with the
child of the Pharaoh she had no choice
but to tell the high priest about her
relationship with seti the first the
high priest told her that her sin
against Isis was so severe that she
would be tried and likely sentenced to
death in order to protect the Pharaoh
from a scandal benshit avoided the trial
by taking her own life Dorothy finally
understood everything that was happening
to her for the next few years she worked
at various jobs at a theater owned by
her parents but then she got her big
break in 1931 a position opened up in
London writing for an Egyptian public
relations magazine the 30s were a tricky
time in Egypt though it was officially
declared independent from the United
Kingdom in 1922 the UK was still heavily
involved in the governing of the country
Dorothy used her new position at the
magazine to advocate for Egyptian
nationalism and full Independence while
working for the magazine she began
corresponding with a wealthy Egyptian
man named Amon Abdel mcguid in 1933
mcguid proposed she accepted and finally
traveled to Egypt for the first time in
her life the first time in this life
right and when she stepped off the boat
in Cairo she fell to her knees and
kissed the ground she wept and said I'm
finally home and if Dorothy Edie really
was reincarnated now she'd have a chance
to prove it
[Music]
Dorothy's marriage was off to a rocky
start her husband's family was wealthy
and didn't like how open Dorothy was
about her past life she was more
committed to Egyptian culture than her
husband's family was and she was
outspoken about it after a few years
Dorothy and maguid divorced but not
before she gave birth to his son who she
named seti you wasn't Saidi to guys she
was a partying with her back in the day
yup so she names a kid after the X
that's bad for him I hadn't thought of
it that way well that's like what you
pay me for man so Dorothy Edie changed
her name to amsetti which means mother
of seti this is how women were known in
ancient Egypt in 1935 she took a job
with Egypt's Department of Antiquities
she was the first woman ever hired but
she quickly made a name for herself as a
respected scholar she published essays
and articles about ancient Egypt she
translated documents in hieroglyphics
though Dorothy Eady had no formal
training she became known as an expert
in the field finally in 1952 Dorothy was
able to take a job in abados the town
where she believed she lived in abados
she became known as an eccentric by the
locals she observed ancient Egyptian
religion she walked Barefoot everywhere
and she would spend her nights praying
and sleeping in the Egyptian temples in
1957 the new chief of Antiquities wanted
to test Dorothy he admitted that she had
an uncanny understanding about the
ancient Egyptian Egyptian culture but he
didn't really believe she lived in the
temple of seti thousands of years ago so
one night he escorted her to the temple
the only light they had was a torch he
then asked her to take him to different
parts of the temple at this point
nothing had been published about the
layout of the temple and Dorothy had
never been there before in his life
right Dorothy was able to guide him
anywhere he asked to go with no map and
no light she knew every inch of the
temple after his sixth attempt to stump
her he gave up one of her recurring
dreams or memories depending on what you
believe was of The Gardens of the Temple
of seti but those had not yet been
discovered by archaeologists Dorothy
told scientists where to find the
gardens they excavated and they found it
she said if they dug on the north side
of the temple in a specific spot they
would find a hidden tunnel sure enough
the tunnel was there in 1964 she turned
60 years old and by Egyptian law she was
supposed to retire But Not only was she
the first one woman hired by the
department of Antiquities she was given
special permission to keep working she
was too valuable of a resource to let go
egyptologists couldn't explain how but
she was able to make countless
discoveries just by remembering though
her specialty was the Temple of seti the
first in abados she did claim to have
knowledge of other ancient Egyptian
sites for example she said the Lost Tomb
of Nefertiti was underneath the tomb of
her stepson Tutankhamun was she under
King Tut well Dorothy made this claim in
1972. Tutankhamun's tomb was found in
1922 though the tomb had been studied
for 50 years there was no evidence of a
chamber there oh but I love it when you
do this in 2015 radar Imaging
Technologies show there actually was a
chamber right where she said it would be
she also said there was a small Library
underneath one of the feet of the Sphinx
okay okay my turn go ahead she said
there's a room under the Sphinx nobody
believes her years later they do a scan
and bada bing bada boom there's a room
down here yep Yahtzee
[Music]
about 30 of Americans including almost
25 percent of Christians believe in
reincarnation reincarnation might be
fringe science or pseudoscience in the
western world but in the East
reincarnation is viewed differently it's
a central part of Hinduism Buddhism and
Sikhism and several other religions for
about a quarter of the world's
population almost 2 billion people
reincarnation is essential belief the
Dalai Lama the spiritual leader of
Tibetan Buddhism is said to be The
Reincarnation of pemadorji the first
Dalai Lama who died in 1474. the current
Dalai Lama who was born in 1935 is the
14th incarnation of pemadorji when the
Dalai Lama dies senior Tibetan Monks
conduct an elaborate search to find his
next Incarnation this search involves
Consulting oracles interpreting visions
and reading spiritual signs the senior
monks may find Clues from the deceased
body of The Dalai Lama such as the
direction it faces if the body is
cremated the direction of the smoke is
monitored as a potential indicator for
the direction of the rebirth the current
Dalai Lama was found at the age of two
after a senior monk saw his village and
house in a vision the boy then named
lamo thundup was able to identify items
that belonged to the previous Dalai Lama
including a drum used for rituals and a
walking stick even though I consider
myself an open-minded skeptic of the
topics we cover in the channel
reincarnation is a subject I've always
been drawn to there's comfort in the
thought that death is not the end that
her physical life is just a temporary
experience meant to teach us lessons to
prepare us for our next life or to
prepare us for what comes after Dorothy
Edie is one of the most compelling cases
for reincarnation that I've ever seen
but is this really evidence Skeptics
will point out that while Dorothy 80 was
able to identify many Egyptian tombs
tunnels and rooms she also got plenty of
things wrong and some believe that when
Dorothy hit her head falling down the
stairs she injured her brain this injury
caused her to have foreign accent
syndrome which is a real thing the
injury also caused her to develop
obsessive-compulsive disorder with her
Obsession being ancient Egypt there's no
question that if she developed this
Obsession at three or four years old she
become very skilled and knowledgeable
about the subject we know for a fact
that Dorothy 80 was institutionalized
multiple times for mental health issues
also all the stories about Dorothy's
early life come from Dorothy herself the
fall her experience in the museum the
trance writing the time she was tested
in the darkness of the temple there's no
evidence any of this happened we have to
take her out of word but that's the
skeptic's point of view even famous
egyptologists who notoriously dislike
anything mystical said that Dorothy's
knowledge of Egypt was beyond simple
intuition it was uncanny now they
stopped short of saying she was
reincarnated but nobody denies her
contributions to the study of ancient
Egypt Dorothy Edie has been called the
patron saint of egyptology she lived out
out her remaining years near abados
walking distance to the seti's temple
the place since childhood that she
considered home she finally died in 1981
but I can't help but wonder is there a
child out there somewhere right now
having dreams and Visions she can
explain visions of a green garden in the
desert visions of an oasis once again
calling her home
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the white files if you had
fun or learned anything do us a favor
and like subscribe comment share that
stuff really helps and like most topics
we cover on this channel today's topic
was recommended by you so if there's a
story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips and if
you like the Y files you have to thank
our patreon members they're the ones who
make this channel possible and if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon it's cheap
Bennett spun or grab something from the
Wi-Fi store that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you